what's up brother patrick how are you
doing i'm uh with a girlfriend of almost
three years
and we just found out that we were
pregnant all right how old are you man
um almost 23. almost 23. okay cool
and we're freaking out
you say that so joyfully as though if i
don't continue to laugh my way through
this i will
spontaneously combust is that where
you're at yeah yeah
man all right so she with you right now
uh
no she i'm i'm on my lunch break right
now okay
all right so 23 you've been with the
same girl for three years
and now y'all are having a kid how far
along are you
um just a month or two really early on
okay so you haven't even got past so
you're just at four or five weeks six
seven weeks
right okay very cool all right so you're
freaking out what does that even mean
man that means something different to
everybody what does freaking out mean
yeah so basically whenever we took the
test we
just were like in disbelief like okay
this
is actually happening and um we're kind
of just
at a kind of a loss um at
what to do next honestly um we've been
doing a lot of talking on like
whether we should keep it or not put up
for adoption
we just don't know really where to begin
so we're
looking at guidance for that gotcha so
three years with the same person
is this somebody you're gonna spend the
rest your life with uh that's a plan
yeah
i mean you're three years in bro you
know all right
[Laughter]
i know it yeah yeah we're yes yeah we're
talking about marriage of course
okay so what about having a babies
freaking you out
a simple fact of being a dad and also
tell my parents
what do you do for a living man i'm a
banker
at one of the local banks here in
oklahoma okay so you're a banker do you
go to college
um i am taking a hiatus right now okay
that was awesome management's
restructuring man all right so you're
taking a hiatus all you have to say is
no i'm not going to school you don't
even have to explain it to me man
um i like how you have a built-in fancy
fancy excuse for
no i dropped out for right now but i'll
go back at some point hopefully all
right so
and what's your wife do man our
girlfriend sorry if y'all whatever
girlfriend
future wife uh she's a manager at a
clothing store
manager at a clothing store okay so when
you
number one take your parents off the
thing you're 23 dude you're a banker
what does that even mean by the way are
you a loan officer are you a teller
um basically teller type do you use
big language to make people think you're
more than you are
no not really because you said you're a
banker and
i'm hiatus those are big like
you're a pretty good guy huh
i don't really like to talk about myself
honestly why not that's the main
main thing you just called the show with
about a million listeners to it
like uh right i know so why
why are you self-deprecating
not in a funny way but in like the
serious way why are you undermining
yourself
um i think that more or less just has to
do with
um i mean honestly i have no clue
honestly i'm just trying to
come up with something on the spot but
i'm not sure why does a 23 year old guy
with a full-time job
kiera's mom and dad thinks right now
they gonna ground you what are they
gonna do you still live with them
no no no we're we're uh living together
okay my girlfriend okay so y'all are
been together three years you're playing
married
on tv and
now you have a are pregnant she's
pregnant
what about this freaks you out other
than
see what i'm getting at like you've got
your
no 23 year old has their life together
but for a vast majority of them
you're on your way man you got a job you
are learning a trade
in a a madhouse of an industry right
your wife or your fiance keep calling
your wife your girlfriend is
a manager at a clothing store
you all are living together i mean come
get something deeper man because
you're not selling me on why this isn't
yeah this is out of order yeah
this isn't in our plan yeah is it gonna
make
for hard conversations with our family
yeah but you're not selling me on
why this is worth freaking out other
than yeah this is different than we
thought
and now we're in it yeah right yeah i
think that's the main thing is just
um about having those uh hard
conversations and
um really kind of going
going from there yeah and like what to
do next and
everything like that it's just also just
everything sped up like a million miles
really quick yeah dude okay yeah so
i'm gonna give you the opposite i waited
my wife and i dated for
off and on for five years then we
were married for eight years before we
had our son
and i was not ready for it then
i was dramatic and it was like oh my
gosh
what what and i had all this drama and
all this
i'm not ready and shut up dude like
and that's me telling myself to shut up
right so right i don't know very many
people
who are ever quote unquote ready and if
they think they're ready there's
they're super not because you can have
no idea what's coming
right both on
the hey this is more exhausting than we
thought this would be more expensive
than we thought
and more importantly on the other side
in a million years i would not have
waited eight years to have kids had i
known what it would do for my capacity
to love to to experience love
to experience parts of myself that i
didn't know existed
to fall deeper in love with the person
i'd been with for what 12 13 years up to
that point had no idea
and it was this idea like this master
idea that was
life isn't about your plans it's about
who you are
what you do and who you choose to be
when life happens at you
right right so you probably had when
were you thinking about
getting married did y'all like talked
about it and you have some dream
schedule yeah yeah we we did a lot of
talking
um before before this and we're thinking
about getting married
um about another one or two years out
okay um and having kids
three to five years out all right dude
you just got half a decade back
congratulations
that's awesome and so
here's the thing i get the freak out
part i get that i'm not i'm
i'm laughing with you dude i get that
like everything just got turned upside
down it got life got
real serious all of a sudden right and i
also tell you're 23
and it's time to be for life to be
serious okay right
never ever ever make
massive decisions against a hard
conversation
okay what i mean by that is
too many people make themselves
clinically insane
clinically insane they shorten their
lifespan
they endure pain and trauma for
years less than that
they they endure less than a great sex
life with their with their partner they
endure less than a good job
because they are scared of having a hard
conversation
and they just punt and punt and punt and
punt
and so i wanted you to flip this around
on you
this can be not in your plan
but one of the most extraordinary things
that ever happens to you
my brother you're going to be a dad
and there is no greater honor on planet
earth than to be a dad
none there's no harder thing to do i'm
being a husband's pretty hard
um but being a dad is the hardest
greatest thing you will ever
ever do right it's it is
the top of the mountain man it is and
you've got a lot to learn and a lot to
grow up on
i want you to get um this is not a
decision that you
and let me let me back out when you say
you're like you're putting all these
options on the table like
be honest are y'all just talking because
this is a crazy season
are you probably gonna have this kid
like where are you guys
yeah um that's a great question thank
you for asking that um
we kind of were talking about not having
it
mainly due to the timing of it and
everything like that
yeah but and there's just this like
ever aching like echo in the like the
back of my head and my heart and
everything like that that's just
basically saying
but what if you know that what if thing
is just like just driving me and saying
like
what if in the future now we won't be
able to have kicks what if
um xyz it's just been
really really heavy where is she
we're on the same page of basically not
having it
but i'm just afraid for
what the future will hold and what
things will happen are possible things
will happen like will it impact our
relationship will it
impact um her chances of getting
pregnant in the future
you know all of that stuff um whenever
we
quote unquote are already a half kegs
and i know that if you know i say hey
what if we have the kid um completely
and you know it'll be ours won't be
anyone else's we won't put it for
adoption or anything like that
i know that she'll be like i know that
she would say
okay i'm okay with that um
she's kind of indifferent on what to do
and that's just kind of
the most nerve-wracking thing about it i
have a hard time believing that she's
indifferent
yeah uh are you gonna ask you this are
you hard to be
firm around no i'm i'm one of the
most outgoing people that um like i've
been told that
is like people can't come to me for
things that
um like that are
different or weird or a weird situation
i can kind of help point them in the
right direction on
okay that's what to do next action
but hey i do that for a living brother
and i've got people in my life that do
that for me
because it's hard to do with a mirror
right right
so say that out loud i'm gonna be a dad
gonna be a dad what did you feel man
besides the existential terror that
every new almost soon-to-be dad is gonna
feel
i feel whenever i say i'm going to be a
dad
i i don't know i kind of feel
of course scared but more or less just
like
okay we'll kind of figure it out
more or less awesome alright so here's
the deal
everything in your life when you have
this kid
i hear it in you man i hear it in you
when you have this kid
everything's going to change and you are
going to find yourself walking six
inches taller
you're going to find yourself exhausted
you're going to find yourself thinking
i'm probably going back to school or i'm
going to get more hours all those things
are going to change
right there's a before and after there
you are at that point now
i want you but uh but before i move on
but dude let me just tell you let me
tell you
and you're not asking my opinion i'm
just giving it to you
i can't tell you what it's like
to hold that kid i can't tell you what
it's
like when that tiny little hand grabs
your finger and squeezes so hard that
you think your finger's gonna come off
i can't tell you what it's like for my
friends who've adopted when they bring
their kid home for the first time
and you sit down and that in that glow
of
terror and joy and love that you didn't
know you were capable of
in fear and you look at the person
you're married to and you're like what
did we do
and here we are all of that okay
i can also hear it in you you want to be
confident
so hard any which way and you're not and
that freaks you out you're probably a
confident guy who's just taking a hiatus
right
you're a confident guy and then suddenly
this happened i would be willing to bet
my car
and it's not nice right so you're not
going to get a lot out of it if i'm
wrong
i would bet that your wife your
girlfriend god i keep calling your wife
sorry brother
that's not i'm not trying to be
subliminal or anything like i'm trying
to be tricky i just keep going her that
um
i can't imagine that your girlfriend's
indifferent
yeah she has to have some feelings and
thoughts on this that either she
is uncomfortable saying out loud to you
or she's afraid of what you're gonna say
or if she is inside of her
so thrilled to be like we're gonna have
oh my gosh
but if she's not getting that from you
she's gonna soft play it and
downplay it and lo low drive it because
she's worried does that make sense
yeah and so if you can go home tonight
and hold both of her hands and look her
in the eye and say
i'm gonna be a dad
like we're doing this right
and you can make a journey to nashville
from from
oklahoma we'll marry you over here like
anthony o'neil
is an ordained minister of some sort
he'll marry you here right we'll do it
for free
and you know what i'm saying like let's
get this done and
we're gonna figure this out and then
we're gonna have a conversation with our
parents and they're gonna be like oh my
gosh and they're gonna be that way for
about two seconds
and then they're gonna realize we're
about to be grandparents and then the
game's on
right and then everybody rallies up and
you're gonna get more nonsense advice
and more like well you know your [ __ ]
all that stuff that's just part of the
deal
but before if if that's not in the plan
if you are uncomfortable that i want you
to you and her go talk to a professional
therapist
tomorrow okay
this is red alert for your relationship
this is red alert for your mental health
for her mental health this is
red alert for everybody okay yeah and
they will give you some tools on how to
move forward
how to have these conversations with
people that you're scared to have these
conversations with
how to wrap your head around hey dude
we're gonna have we're gonna have a
child
right we're in this now
but i want you to hear me say you're not
crazy for
thinking everything went sideways it is
it did i don't want you
to think you're crazy because you guys
had a plan and suddenly your plans just
went up in smoke and now you've got some
major things one of which is
we're created a human right
i also want you to realize you're 23
you're gonna have to have
start having hard conversations that's a
part of your life from this point
forward
this is gonna be the hard conversation
to have right
i also want you to um
not minimize this one awesome thing
brother you're about to be a dad
you're about to be a dad your
girlfriend's about to be a mom
and this is big big stuff right thank
you for calling
you're right to freak out now go make
the right decisions
on getting the tools you need to go be a
great mom to be a great dad
to go be a great husband go get
connected here thank you for the call
let me know how it goes whenever you
have your conversations i want to hear
how that goes
and what the next steps are going to be
thanks for your call patrick